vamos a resolver este problema dice un
círculo tiene perímetro 20 pib tiene un
arco de longitud 221 / 18 p cuál es la
medida del ángulo central en grados y
aquí nos dan el dibujo este de aquí es
el círculo que tiene perímetro 20 y este
es el ángulo central que nos dan y
además aquí tenemos el arco que nos
marcan que mide 221 entre 18 pi bueno
para resolver este problema basta
recordar la fórmula que ya vimos en el
vídeo anterior que nos dice lo siguiente
nos dice que la longitud de arco que en
este caso sería este cacho de acá que
voy a poner en color rojo para que
coincida la longitud de arco 221 entre
18 por pi dividido entre el perímetro
del círculo entre 20 pi
20.000 es igual a la medida del ángulo
central que es lo que necesitamos
determinar déjame llamarle theta que
está dividido entre la cantidad total de
grados en un círculo es decir 360 grados
esto de aquí nos va a dar la medida de
theta en grados si quisiéramos encontrar
la medida de ett en radiales tendríamos
que multiplicar después el valor de teta
por pi y dividir entre 180 grados vale
pero bueno por el momento vamos a
encontrarlo en grados porque es lo que
nos están pidiendo por acá sale bueno
entonces para hacer eso debemos
multiplicar ambos lados de esta igualdad
por 360 grados 360 grados para que de
este lado se cancele y vamos a ver qué
nos queda 360 grados nos queda del lado
izquierdo nos queda 360 grados x 221 voy
a agarrar el color rojo 221 por pi
dividido entre este 18 18 x este 20 x
20p y eso de ahí es igual a teta teta
muy bien bueno pues vamos a cancelar
cosas aquí a la izquierda el pis se
cancela con pi 360 entre 20 es lo mismo
que 36 entre 236 entre 2 es igual a 18
18 y 18 entre 18 es igual a 1 de esta
forma nos queda que 221 es igual a teta
221 grados sale entonces este ángulo de
aquí me de mi de 221 grados